Star Wars is the most iconic Sci-Fi film saga
of all time, grossing over 6.5 billion dollars
with film tickets alone.
George Lucas has created a world that is part
of our everyday conversations.
With long gaps between trilogy’s fans are
eager to learn more about their favorite characters,
lands, weapons, ships and anything else Star
Wars related.
With thousands of talented artists working
on these films there is more than meets the
eye when watching the first time around.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of the ten Most
Paused Scenes in Star Wars Movies.
Flags at Maz Kanata's Bar
The outside of Maz Kanata’s bar is ornamented
with flags that represent numerous moments
in the Star Wars saga.
When the team walks into the bar look above
and see what famous symbols you can spot.
The flags include several symbols from the
pod-racing scene in “The Phantom Menace”
but one is more important to fans.
Boba Fett wears a symbol on his outfit in
“The Empire Strikes Back” and “Return
of the Jedi”; this symbol can be seen on
the flags also.
Maybe Boba did survive the Sarlacc Pit!
Ralph McQuarrie Cameo
Without Ralph McQuarrie there would have been
no Star Wars, George Lucas knew his characters
and world he envisioned were perfect for the
silver screen but needed to prove it to 20th
Century Fox.
He hired McQuarrie to help illustrate the
planets, vehicles, and characters that was
in his mind and the rest was history.
Lucas gave McQuarrie a cameo in the film “The
Empire Strikes Back” to cement his place
in Star Wars history.
He walks through Hoth’s Echo Base with a
sketchpad under his arm.
Han Gets Friendly
Han Solo is a ladies man, so much that the
smuggler even stole the heart of the Princess
of Alderaan, Leia.
In “Return of the Jedi,” during the climatic
battle on the planet of Endor Leia and Han
are being attacked by Stormtroopers.
Pinned up against the entrance to the shield
generator bunker that they must destroy, Leia
is shot.
As Han goes in to help her, he gropes her
breast!
Was it deliberate or was it an accident?
Either way Han made it to second base with
a princess.
E.T.
Makes a Cameo
During “The Phantom Menace” numerous Galactic
Senators from around the galaxy surround us.
One group is all too familiar to fans of Steven
Spielberg’s film, “E.T.
The Extra Terrestrial”.
Lucas was kept a promise he made to Spielberg
after the release of E.T.
Back in 1982, Spielberg included a Yoda cameo
and Star Wars toys in E.T. and Lucas promised
that he would add E.T. in his next Star Wars
film.
Only problem was they turned out to be Palpatine
supporters.
George Lucas Cameo
Alfred Hitchcock, Mel Brooks and Quentin Tarrantino
are all directors that enjoy making cameos
in their films, where is George Lucas?
After five Star Wars films you would think
Lucas would join in on the fun.
In his sixth film, “Revenge of the Sith”
Lucas finally makes a cameo alongside his
daughter Katie hidden behind robes and blue
paint.
Lucas plays Senator Baron Papanoida and his
daughter plays Chi Eekway, it only took six
films but the saga creator finally joined
the galaxy on screen.
The 'Millennium Falcon' In the Prequels
The YT-1300 Corellian freighter was already
sixty years old when Han Solo and Chewbacca
made the Kessel Run in 12 parsecs.
So seeing the Millennium Falcon in the prequels
should not be a shock but spotting the ship
is hard.
In “Attack of the Clones” on the planet
of Naboo you can see three-yes three models
of the YT-1300 Corellian freighter.
A popular model on that planet.
If you want to see Han’s falcon before he
took it for his first ride watch “Revenge
of the Sith” and see it dock on Coruscant.
Boba Fett’s Face
Actor Jeremy Bulloch plays villain Boba Fett
in both “The Empire Strikes Back” and
“Return of the Jedi”.
But to know what he looks like you’ll have
to watch for him in “The Empire Strikes
Back” outside of his titular villain’s
costume.
When Luke is tricked into visiting Cloud City
he not only gets a glance of his friends before
they are taken away but we get a glance of
Bulloch.
Bulloch pulls Leia back in this scene only
because the actor who was supposed to play
the part was a no show.
The Outrider
Fans of the novel, “Shadows of the Empire,”
by Steve Perry know that the book describes
the events that take place between “The
Empire Strikes Back” and “Return of the
Jedi.”
One of the main characters was Dash Render
a smuggler and freelancer that flew the Outrider.
In the special edition of “A New Hope”
the CGI artists added the Outrider taking
off from Mos Eisley.
The Kitchen Sink
The film “Revenge of the Sith” opens with
the Battle of Coruscant, it is a vibrant and
eye-popping sequence.
The fight involved so much CGI that the team
at Industrial Light and Magic through everything
at it, including the kitchen sink.
No, we mean that literally.
As Obi-Wan and Anakin fly by, a Repulic cruiser
destroys a Seperatist ship causing parts of
the ship to fly off.
One of those pieces crashes into the Republic
ship and that part is the kitchen sink.
At least we know they wash their hands during
battle.
Rey’s X-Wing Pilot Doll
Fans have been speculating who Rey’s parents
are since they first saw “The Force Awakens”.
Many believe she is the daughter of Luke Skywalker
and one of the reasons is because of a doll
they spotted.
Rey doesn’t have many items in her home
and we only saw one item that was from her
child hood, the doll.
The doll in Rey’s home is a Rebel Alliance
pilot, the same uniform that Luke wore for
quite a while.
Was this a hint to tell us who her parents
are or just a childhood toy?
We will have to wait for the sequels to find
out.
That was our list.
Can you tell us any other moments you pause
during the Star Wars Saga?
Sound off in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
great videos like this one.
Thanks for watching.